sherry is wrapping up our series today
over in sunrise manor it's a large and
diverse area
on the valley's east side live now from
las vegas high with a closer look at
this
wonderful neighborhood sherry good
morning to you that view has been
spectacular all morning long and i guess
campus is starting to fill up a little
bit
you know there aren't a lot of kids on
campus because they've been
uh taking exams online for the end of
the year
but there will be a few and we've seen a
couple of school buses that have come in
we are uh gosh at the top of the east
side of the valley
at las vegas high school it's the oldest
high school
in the city it's been established over a
hundred
years ago and with this this morning
i've got chris welch who is one of the
assistant principals
thanks a lot for being here chris good
morning nice to see you
i did you say las vegas high school a
lot of notables that graduated from here
the namesake for nellis air force base
governor and for former governor and
senator richard bryan
who else graduated from las vegas high
school we have
uh tony basil
who did the oh mickey you're so fine i
know that song
that's a great song
[Music]
bryce harper bryce harper school here
yeah
um i'm trying to think uh lloyd george
for the federal courthouse
yes yes right here in downtown quite a
few we are our
alumni association is very strong filled
with famous people
they support give us some so much
support
so any any former wildcats out there you
should join the
alumni association you said the legacy
of las vegas high school
uh there are generations of las vegas
who have gone
to school here and grandparents that
want to see their grandkids go to school
here
that's right our original campus was
downtown it's now las vegas academy and
we had
we have grandparents and parents that
went to that school
and they brought and they wanted their
students to continue on that tradition
so they
now attend here we've i've seen so many
generations of
families come through this this building
and this
this campus actually uh you moved the
school up here in the mid-1990s that's
why it looks so new
right right 1993 we opened and
had our first class graduate from now
there's a real sense of community here
and and you said that really this is
kind of the heart
of the east side why is that it is it is
the
the center of this community
you know there's there's a few other
high schools around here but everybody
wants to go to las vegas high school
everybody wants to be a wildcat that's
right and y'all really rallied around
each other
and the students during the pandemic and
you're really looking forward to
to this year and next fall what's going
on that's special
we're well welcoming a few months ago we
welcomed back
our students they were all excited to to
to come back and and see their teachers
and we're also going to continue that on
next week in our summer program we have
a few hundred students that are going to
come back they're giving away their
summer break and
just to be back at las vegas high school
that's wonderful and we're right here at
the football field which
you're one of very few high schools
which you're going to have your
graduation ceremonies on your own
football field
that's right we're going to be
graduating next week we'll be graduating
about 600 students
600 that's fantastic june 2nd
congratulations to you and thank you for
letting us be up here you have fantastic
views
and you have such a great faculty and
everyone i've talked to is just
tremendous so
go wildcats and i know you're looking
forward to fall and having all the
students back on campus
so yes thank you thank you chris it was
really a pleasure to talk to you